[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette bergerie de tingwick dans les
bois-francs ressemble à la plupart des
bergeries du québec
le producteur pierre lessard possède 500
brebis qui engendre environ 1000 agneaux
par année les bêtes sont envoyés à
l'abattoir à l'âge de six mois
la majorité de la viande est ensuite
vendus dans les supermarchés
après un an de pandémie les affaires
vont bien que je peux dire aujourd'hui
pour donner une idée de l'état de la
situation aux productions vincee parle
depuis janvier en 2020 la baisse des
prix de l'agneau surtout liée à la
fermeture des restaurants n'aura duré
que quelques semaines
depuis le confinement est une
bénédiction pour les producteurs
québécois
les personnes qui avaient l'habitude
d'aller au restaurant se paie une bonne
bouteille de vin bon faut bien ont
décidé d'essayer de le faire un maison
pour réaliser que baky c'est parce qu'on
peut qu'il soit par la cuisine de
lagnieu encouragements en fait du
gouvernement
de manger local d'encourager locales ont
fonctionné même constat ici à la ferme
le ch est comme montérégie les
restaurants représentait pourtant 35 %
du chiffre d'affaires les clients ont
vraiment répondu à l'appel nous notre
côté on a commencé à offrir un service
de livraison à domicile puis de commande
en ligne
c'est étonnamment ça vraiment bien
marché ça marche encore toujours super
bien on devinait cet engouement lundi à
l'encan de saint-hyacinthe
à quelques jours de pâques c'était une
des plus grosse journée de l'année et
les producteurs attendaient en file pour
vendre leur à nyon mille huit cents
bêtes ont été achetés aux enchères un
prix 30% plus élevés en moyenne qu'en
2019 2021 s'annonce historique
on est parti pour un fait un record à un
prix ça c'est certain
2 en volume en demande ce qu'on a passé
qu'un que les restaurants pour ouvrir
ont continué à rouler quand comme que
vous l'avez comment qu'on fait pour
revenir à demande surtout qu'avec deux
cent mille agneaux par année les
producteurs du québec répond seulement à
la moitié de la demande québécoise
à titre comparatif la nouvelle zélande
ont produit 300 fois plus depuis 28 ans
le chef réputé normand laprise fait des
aliments du terroir sa spécialité et
lannion ne fait pas exception
pineau cite encore beaucoup de petites
filles magritte commence à voir
certaines qui sont plus gros pour moi la
différence en goût c'est si la
nourriture 1 on est ce qu'on mangeait
pis la news du québec je pense qu'en
général est bien nourri et puis c'est ce
qui fait le goût fini dit-il l'époque où
on mange et l'agneau seulement lors des
grandes occasions
sa consommation est devenue plus
fréquentes mais elles restent encore
limitées le canadien moyen mange
seulement 1 kg d'agneau par année ce qui
en 2007 représentait à peine plus de 1 %
de la viande consommée au pays à égalité
avec leveaux le port compte pour 24%
leboeuf 27% et la volaille 45% passer
d'une production émergentes un marginal
maintenant on peut dire qu'on se place
sur les marchés
loin d'être comparable à nous nos
confrères du boeuf du pont mais mais
quand même il ya une place sur le marché
pour cette production le la petite
taille des fermes et la complexité de
l'élevage entre autres en raison de
l'hiver prend toutefois l'agneau d'ici
plus cher souvent 10 $ de plus le kg par
rapport à ceux de la nouvelle zélande ou
de l'australie
pour moi ça vaut le coup ça vous le prix
après je monte à manger deux fois
semaine que d'en manger quatre fois avec
nous de moindre qualité qui pour moi
c'est toujours un côté très social de
manche et la caf
les producteurs d'agneaux du québec
pourront-ils augmenter le rythme de
production et répondre à la demande
plusieurs comme pierre lessard devront
aussi songer à la relève de gros défi
mais au moins là covin leur a donné un
coup de pouce
ici jean sébacées cloutier radio-canada
thing